I I am obsessed with the new show I love
it so much and Jeremiah like don't you
make me cry right now but the good thing
is you do cry multiple times in the
episode and you know thanks guys that
that is like a page out of my playbook
in the sense that like I don't hold back
I can't hold back I'm incapable and it
is people's lives it is and we know that
and you know
it's it's funny because you know one of
the things like we watch when we watch
other shows are like is anyone really
connecting do they know did they take
the time to get to know them because if
you don't you end up with a house that
might look really beautiful on camera
but then the homeowner walks in and
they're like yeah this is pretty but it
has nothing to do with me so that's not
for us like we really get to know the
people that we're working for the truth
is at our core the show is about love
and about connection and we get to
connect to people through design but we
get to also show people how a family
that looks like ours that may not look
like a lot of other people's family how
we love how we connect how we share how
we tell story and we get to meet all
these amazing people and they're so nice
and they're so vulnerable and they're so
open and I it breaks me open every time
oh you guys it really really does like
I've always had a dream to work with
someone that I was in a relationship
with I'll do it with you
guys
yeah next season
I'll take such good care of you you have
no idea I mean honestly you have no idea
the spaces the spaces we could create
come on the lives we could change
it I mean I don't even think there's
room I don't know no it'll be fine I'll
say it we need you I'll say them with
your girls
which actually yeah you have four kids
together
exactly right some like weird E.T Brady
Bunch yeah exactly exactly yeah how do
you how do you do it since I've never
had the luxury and the privilege of
collaborating with my partner advice I
can enter I think well no no you watch
he doesn't the first thing is no
um the um he was like what are you gonna
say yeah but no our relationship is
always the most important thing it
always is because you know the truth is
we do work together and sometimes
they're 14-hour days and then we come
home and the kids are hungry or someone
has a fever or whatever it is and if we
don't put our relationship first before
everything then everything else falls
apart and so nothing's as important as
that
nothing I'm not I'm just not close
enough and by our relationship you know
I know
how to do that what's something that
like well it's going to shock you but I
like to have a lot of talks
when we first met they'd be like what
are we talking about now it truly what's
left I'm like lost within like the First
Once something goes back like eight
minutes of conversation on the same
topic I want the Box checked I'm ready
to move on I think and Jerry's like I
think we just need to go back honestly I
think to the kids art cabinets
okay well I have a little gift for you
and let me I'm excited really why
because I just want to see if you guys
you know agree on the design of it okay
if this thing has a tail like last time
I was here you and I are gonna have
no conversation like when I chased you
around Jeremy
I thought it was
this I
[Applause]
is this a metaphor yeah
our kids are gonna love it yeah I just
thought it was so you guys I yeah no it
really is a you know what I feel like
I feel like this dog a lot yeah
and you know one thing that I've always
felt about gifts is like when you
receive something this beautiful and
exquisite it's like you know you want to
be known everyone wants to be seen
everyone wants to be heard and I feel
known yeah you really see us I really do
I don't know
[Applause]
because Nate and Jeremiah are sticking
around to play a little friendly
competition and it just may involve a
gift for our audience
[Applause]
[Music]